if you win tonight that would be a
complete sweep what would that mean to
you
that I that I chose the right career
it sounds ridiculous but it is true to
even be nominated to even be accepted
into the academy or into the Screen
Actors Guild and like hold those cards
get nominated that's another whole level
and so like getting the Accolade itself
that year is like yeah it's it's it's
the ultimate but it's also unnecessary
because I've already gotten this uh kind
of Acceptance in a way I feel like
validation and like time and to keep
going yeah that's
actors desperately need it's not
you know the director needs to say you
did a good job
you know what I mean I get it and so
when your fellow actors are like you did
a great job that was a great take you're
like you didn't have to say that yeah
and then and then all of a sudden
whatever it's great and I know you've
been busy so it's amazing that you got
to be here tonight I am like
exactly dead center into shooting a
movie in Toronto with one of my favorite
directors of all time and so it was just
crazy like momentum and then like
stopping but like I'm taking a break for
a really good reason of course real
quick we recently spoke with Renee Rapp
who's of course playing Regina George in
the Mean Girls movie and she told us she
will call you she'll do whatever she has
to do to get you guys to be in this
movie what's the update I'm still hoping
for a miracle it's not it's not really
up to us is it but you're but you're so
in right all four of us are 100
into it yeah if you were a part of it
would you want to reprise Your Role or
would it be something else no I think
well because Renee is like playing
Regina so Rachel wouldn't play Regina
she would play somebody else like maybe
the mothers of our characters
that's what I was thinking but listen I
haven't seen a script
foreign